you
way back when I was six years old
reading comic books and I love comic
books in the centerfold of a Superman
comic book was a description not a comic
but text of how to build something
called a crystal radio and what
fascinated me was that you can build it
out of pot you could find in your house
on the street at no cost I mean I needed
an empty toilet paper roll some wire my
father's old razor blade a pencil lead
that was pretty much free I needed an
earphone which I stole from the candy
stores telephone booth and I needed
something called a variable capacitor I
had no idea what that was but I know i
could buy it down a canal street so my
mother took me down in the subway i
walked with the first electronic shop
banging my fist on the table and said I
need a variable capacitor and the guy
said what size and it blew my cover so I
explained what i wanted the voice is I
know just what you need so we sold us
for a few pennies this variable
capacitor I brought it home wyd it up
and I heard music coming out of the
earphone no battery no power basically
free now this was clearly magic I
decided I better figure out how this
works and that's what launched me on
this career if you will of engineering
and I'm still trying to figure out how
to work how it works
went to graduate school that are mighty
and there I started working for the
legendary Claude Shannon the man who
invented and created information theory
brilliant guy and he was he was then and
still is my role model and I noticed
that all my classmates were doing their
PhD research on the area that he had
created information theory and in my
mind this was a very crowded area
Shannon had done most of the easy good
work solid work what was left was hard
and probably inconsequential so I
imagined but I was surrounded by
computers both at MIT and at MIT Lincoln
Laboratory where I spent my summers
working and I said one day these
computers are going to have to talk to
each other and there was no adequate way
by which they could do so so this really
challenged me this is a good problem
it'll probably be important there's a
lot of low-hanging fruit let's go for it
so I started working in the area which
eventually became the internet and what
I did for my dissertation was to
basically create the mathematical theory
of data networks suggested and
introduced the idea of taking messages
and breaking them up into fixed length
blocks we now call those things packets
and develop the underlying technology of
packet switching which now drives the
internet backbone
so September second 1969 the first
packets which we now call those things
routers arrived in my laboratory to UCLA
it was based on a design that we had
specified the manufacturer create it
arrived there on the labor day weekend
on the Monday following on the Tuesday
following the labor day we hooked that
switch up to our host computer with UCLA
the host computer was basically a time
shared computer serving the computer
science department at UCLA so we had a
switch and we had a computer it wasn't
going anywhere but I like to say that
that's the day that the infant internet
took its first breath of life this
switch which reported the internet
looked out of the world was born and so
a computer a month later the second node
received their switch up at Stanford
Research Institute otherwise known as sr
I for a mile to the north of us UCLA
they're up in the Bay Area we put a
high-speed line between our switch and
their switch they connected their
computer we had our computer and what we
wanted to do was now talk from our
computer through this very small to node
network to their computer this was
October 29th 1969 so what was the
message we want to send all we want to
do is log in from our computer to their
computer now to log in you have to type
l 0 g and that remote machine is smart
enough to know what you're trying to do
it types the inv you ready to go Charlie
climb my program and myself build to Val
up at the other end and we had a
telephone connection so we could
communicate and make sure we watched
what happened so we type the L and say
you get the L just got the l tap the or
you get the out got the o top the G got
the Jeep crash the sry computer crashed
so the first message ever on the
internet was low as in lo and behold
we couldn't have anticipated a shorter
more prophetic more succinct message
than low
two months before the September date on
July third of 1969 a press release was
put out of UCLA and in there I'm quoted
in writing I've got a copy of the press
release well I do articulate the vision
I had and basically what I said was that
the internet would be always available
always on everywhere that anybody with
any device could get on at any time and
it would be invisible just like
electricity is invisible what I did not
anticipate was that my 99 year old
mother would be on the internet and she
was until she passed away two years ago
I didn't see the social side our vision
then was computers talking to each other
and people talking to computers but not
people to people and of course that's
what's driving the internet these days
the communities that form the Facebook's
all the social networking all the email
is about people communicating with each
other miss that side of it
and there's a number of phases the
internet will go through and some of
which we're in right now one of them is
what i like to call nomadic computing it
used to be that people believed that
they would desk-bound in fact that they
had three wonderful capabilities in
their home or office environment that a
high-speed before high pot high-speed
computer a laptop or workstation good
connectivity Ethernet gigabit access
perhaps and a network administrator to
help make it all work network
administrator in an office typically
will load the software present new
hardware configure the machine keep the
network up and running nowadays when we
take our laptops and we take them out of
our offices or homes and go on the road
we leave behind the networking and we
leave behind that network administrator
well wherever you go now you're going to
find high-speed access but that network
administrator you don't have with you
and for a while and on in our evolving
here when I came into an office it would
be almost impossible for me to get my
laptop to work with their network you
need an administrator to combine
reconfigured give you a password maybe
change your IP address etc nowadays a
lot of that is automatic but the ability
to provide the same class of service
that you have in your office when you're
out on the road it's what we call
nomadic computing and that's begun to
happen rather well these days and some
parts of the world it's harder but
nowadays when you travel you probably
don't think about it you just log on to
the local Wi-Fi network and you're up
and running it wasn't always that way
it's still a little complicated at times
if you have a virtual private network or
static IP address or some other special
thing on your machine you may have
trouble configuring it you need some
automatic ways to do it no matter
computer but that's that's maturing now
second phase most people believe that
cyberspace sits behind the screen of
their workstation or their cell phone
the move that's going to happen is
starting to happen is that cyberspace is
coming out from behind that screen and
enter in our physical environment for
example the walls of this room should
know I'm here I should be able to walk
into this room the room should know it's
me and I should be able to get services
from this environment I should be able
to ask for example where is a high-speed
printer or high resolution display or
your projector and the room should
answer me in speech maybe in the
hologram maybe with a display that pops
up this chair my fingernails my
eyeglasses my desk my automobile my
hotel room the internet should be
everywhere and what's going to make that
happen what we call embedded technology
the small micro or nano devices that are
actuators senses logic processing memory
displays microphones speakers embedded
in our environment so the internet
presence will be everywhere it'll follow
me around in fact many of the things we
carry around today these these
smartphone devices and such like it's an
example of the internet coming out and
being in our environment wherever we go
but they'll be embedded as well the next
thing is the smart spaces that I'm
describing where cyberspace comes out
and reaches into our physical world will
disappear like I said earlier they'll
become invisible they'll just be there
everything will be internet-enabled
that's the second phase the third phase
is ubiquity which means wherever I go I
should be accepted as a friendly instead
of an alien that's no matter computing
the environment in which I come should
be a smart space at the second phase but
this capability but everywhere I go now
one of the first ways in which we had
ubiquitous internet access was many
years ago when the dial-up modem became
available
like take a device in any way I could
find a telephone I could get on the
internet and reach out to the world low
speed clunky noisy not reliable but
ubiquitous well that capability is now
being deployed and much higher speeds
much more reliability some of the 3g the
4g networks the environments become a
new and alive with ubiquitous capability
the fourth phase is what i like to call
intelligent agents smart intelligent
software agents we deploy these things
into the internet and they provide
services to us they know what we want
they reach out and gather news for us
they give us alerts they tell us about
what's happening in the environment at
our service on a customized basis what i
like to call mass personalization where
where everyone has their profile their
preferences their privileges their needs
the environment knows about it and the
software agents deliver the services
that you asked for and control a lot of
the larger level services of our society
so they provide functionality we see
that today our whole finance system is
based on some of these software agents
and they've caused some problems like
the other day when the Dow dipped by a
thousand points that was software agents
acting on response to basically signals
that they received which in fact or
erroneous so the last phase and now we
walk into the applications domain is
that everything is going mobile and so
the applications will be largely focused
on mobility geographically focused
applications geolocation personalization
delivering services wherever we go based
on what we need who we are where we are
and what we're looking for and those
applications some of the social
networking applications have been
centered on that aspect of it a lot of
the SMS and the twitter is based on the
device you're having your hand possibly
your machine but mobile applications
where it's coming in
and in fact many of the services these
days are enormously profitable for
example have you ever purchased a
ringtone for yourself own they cost 99
cents now when I ask people that
question the older generation never the
young adoration a fair number but the
fact is that's a five billion dollar
industry as of a few years ago things
like delivering the video sports
entertainment all of those are
multi-billion dollar industries based on
services do I deliver to you at the
laptop or to your mobile device so the
the world is full of ways to entertain
yourself but one of the failings of the
internet now that we're talking about
applications that people are spending
money on is that there's not really good
ways to monetize things on the internet
we know there are three things that sell
actually for sex celebrity entertainment
and shopping those things people have
wanted to spend money on but most of the
rest of it people expect to have free in
this whole issue of mindset saying the
internet that live as free services
information has distorted in many ways
the typical business models that people
are used to